aj mike florio here how are you pal
how are you doing i'm doing great i'm
doing great i appreciate some of your
time i know it's a crazy day
i i have to ask you first and foremost
about that play where you make the catch
and you were not going to be denied the
touchdown walk me through what happened
there
um i was just trying to i had a slight
route and i was just i knew i knew we
needed the first down
it was 30-10 and all that he kind of
stopped my momentum just i said he kind
of stopped my own room and i just kind
of went with you
uh just trying to just throw him off a
little bit and then the rest i was just
trying to get her first down you know my
teammates came to help me up uh
pushed me in the bag uh two guys i'll
threw a couple guys off me and
and uh they pushed me in the back when i
was in amazon what was it that happened
before the game
uh you know guys this guy's just turning
in uh the coach
and the coaches just came over there and
i was like did it really
you know i was just in the way i was i
was at the thousand in the wrong place
at the wrong time i was trying to keep
the peace
you know because they're coaches not
like would play this but i was just
trying to keep everybody calm
to separate everybody and get ready to
play so i mean
things were heated how did it all get
started
we only saw so much of it on tv you had
guys out on their logo is that what
ticked them off
um i really don't know uh i think some
words were scared
and they said some very bad they they
kind of rushed to feel like they were
close
you know but they definitely set the
tone up the game they thought that's
what they knew
what type
people will say that once the game
starts none of that stuff means anything
did any of that carry over
i can't think of two teammates who
entered the draft at the receiver
position at the same time
who've had more of an impact on the
league than you and dk metcalf
how often do you talk to him we talk all
the time we talk all the time we discuss
we discuss what's going on
and he's off to a really great start
he's doing really good right now uh like
we all like we all talked about and
obviously
we all worked out together so we kind of
we kind of talked about those things you
know uh
he's he's doing really well right now
and i'm proud of him
how much of what he's doing motivates
you oh most definitely there's no
government
we both talk about uh where we want to
be in
his league and so uh
by him doing good i am balling on sunday
you know it definitely gives you
motivation
to match the energy you know so we can
stand and talk about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports